I saw myself as the weakest person God
ever created.
I got called nigger every day of my life
growing up,
living in a small town.
The uh,
one of the high ups in the KKK son sat
behind me two classes,
so he called me nigger all the time.
I got my first car,
they spray painted nigger ruin to kill
you on it.
And I was weighing like 297 pounds.
So I was just an insecure,
scared kid.
But the best thing that happened to me,
no one helped me.
I wasn't going to be a punk kid all my
life.
So the way I could turn it around was to
suffer.
I had to build calluses in my brain the
same way I built calluses on my hands.
So I brought against.
But the role is record for posts a long
time ago.
But I failed at it twice and I did
67,000
pullups trying to break this record.
So to do 4,030
pull ups,
I had to do $67,000
for training for that.
Wow.
And so what I realized is for me to
become the man,
I wanted to become a saw myself as the
weakest person God ever created.
But I never blamed God for anything he
did to me.
So I wanted to change that to be the
hardest man ever created.
Am I that?
I don't know,
but he had to have a goal in my goal
when I was sitting there not going to
school,
being bullied,
being having no self esteem.
My goal was the only person that could
turn this person around is me.
I was so driven.
I'm not going to say motivated.
[inaudible] motivation's crap.
Motivation comes and goes.
When you're driven,
whatever's in front of you will get
destroyed.
We live in an external world.
Everything is is you get to see it,
touch it.
It's external.
If you can for the rest of your life,
live inside of yourself.
Stop listening to people who are calling
you fat,
gay,
transsexual,
nigger.
Everything that is makes no sense.
All these insecure people putting their
insecurities on you,
you got to flush it out.
You gotta just be whoever the Hell God
or whatever the hell you believe in.
If you believe in nothing but yourself,
I don't care where it is.
You got to take everything and throw it
away.
You have to believe in one thing and
that is yourself and I'm not saying
don't believe in God and we should
believe in,
but right now for you to find greatness
in yourself,
you're not going to find it by looking
in a book or by even hearing me,
I may give you the spark,
but you've got to go inside yourself to
find it.
How to ask the question,
how are you going to do that?
Thicken your skin,
become more of a human being.
Don't be afraid of the reflection in the
mirror because that's all you can be
afraid of.
Once you overcome the reflection in the
mirror,
on the other side is greatness.
That's what people are saying by me
running.
I'm callus in my mind.
I'm not training for a race.
I'm training for life.
I'm training for the time.
When I get that 2:00
in the morning call,
my mom is dead or something happens.
Tragic in life.
I don't fall apart.
I'm training my mind and my body,
my spirit,
so it's all one so I can handle what
life is gonna throw at me because the
life I've lived,
it throws a whole bunch at you and if
you're not physically and mentally
prepare for that,
you're just going to crumble and you're
good for nobody.
In Times of suffering,
what we do is we forget how hard we
really are because that's what suffering
is.
Suffering's a test.
That's all it is.
Suffering is the true test of life.
The beauty is remembering this young,
dumb what people called Nigger is now
where I'm at today,
and that is when you finally get to that
point,
for me,
it's forever lasting peace.
Greatness isn't running towards your
miles at the time of doing 40,000
posts of being a seal.
Greatness is whatever the hell you
dreamed of in your own mind.
You got to first see it.
You got first create this vision in your
mind and the national.
I come into play once you create this
vision in your mind is how am I going to
get there?
Now we're all we are all great.
No matter if,
if you think you're dumb,
think you're fat.
No matter if you are fat,
no matter if you've been bullied or no
matter if you just got back from Iraq or
Afghanistan and you have no legs or your
arms or whatever,
man,
we all have greatness.
It just got to find the courage.
You got to find the courage to put your
bose headphones on and silence the noise
out of this world in defined it that
sets you apart from everybody else,
and that's.